there are things in life i don't like
like mayonnaise on burgers or pineapple
on pizza but there's only one thing that
i truly cannot stand you gotta sell
something i don't know what you gotta
sell but you gotta sell something this
is what's happening tonight it's the
master class on how to go from zero to a
seven figure revenue business when
people say oh is this get rich quick you
better hope that it is the get rich
quick schemes that's actually how this
channel started with the series called
fake gurus dedicated to exposing all the
grifters out there who got wealthy by
selling people on how to get wealthies
that sort of thing and there was a point
at which
believe it or not
we were winning the war the message was
getting out there hey
don't buy a get rich quick ski but if
i'm being honest
we've been away for a while talking
about krypto right and i've been slowly
but surely hearing whispers on the wind
that the grifters and fake gurus
they're back
and this time they've teamed up
like a gang of hyenas they've realized
their safety in numbers and to be honest
i don't know if i can stop them
i'm talking of course about jordan
belfort and brian rose's alliance and
course that's right the piss drinker of
wall street and actual wall street
fraudster together they have joined
forces and individually sure i could
probably take them but together i'm not
so sure i'm worried that their powers of
persuasion might be too much even for me
coffeezilla the internet detective so i
want to warn you guys ahead of time hold
on to your wallets they may try to take
them from you in this video and we're
going to investigate the return
of the fake gurus here at london real
studios i will be hosting a two-day
crypto defy nft and metaverse mastermind
with the wolf of wall street himself
jordan belfort
[Laughter]
jordan is an industry titan who has
become a household name for his ability
to build multi-million dollar companies
and work with the who's who of business
and the blockchain no wait wait wait
wait pause it real quick okay a lot to
unpack here i feeling pretty unpersuaded
to be honest with you um first thing i
got to say i love how they describe
jordan belford as being famous for
building multi-million dollar businesses
i mean that's one way to frame it i
guess i mean here i was i thought jordan
belfort was famous for scamming people
going to jail and then having leonardo
dicaprio play him in a movie but you
know who am i kidding i'm not hosting
the crypto mastermind the wolf in the
rose that's what they call this by the
way
the other thing i want to talk about
real quick um
is the price for this two-day event this
mastermind i mean how much would you pay
to get the two titans of this industry
teaching you a hundred bucks maybe two
hundred dollars for two days wrong
answer
the price of going to this event is 24
000
ladies and gentlemen that's almost the
price of a bitcoin just so you can hear
the two biggest grifters on earth try to
sell you
on buying bitcoin i mean
they really do pitch themselves in this
as sort of the experts in the field of
cryptocurrency with gourmet catering
throughout each day and a strictly
limited number of places available this
is a unique opportunity to be personally
tutored by two of the most recognizable
former wall street traders who are now
at the forefront of the crypto industry
i mean once again i don't mean to
quibble here but most recognizable
how this is a more shameless duo than if
elizabeth holmes and trevor milton
started a how to start a business master
class i mean you're right you'd be
technically recognizable all right and
can we just talk for a second about
jordan belford i mean what happened to
that guy i thought he was like teaching
how to sell a pin or something instead
he's selling investment advice again and
you'd think he would have learned his
lesson i mean he ruined his life as a
scammer got federally indicted went to
prison and then he came out he probably
thought his life was over only to have
his career resurrected by none other
than leonardo dicaprio you'd think at
that point you've made it right you've
you've been the guy who got struck by
lightning and survived you'd think you'd
hang it up you'd ride it out being the
guy who got the second chance and made
the best of it but instead jordan
belfort
is selling shameless crypto masterminds
and this isn't even his first one the
new york times actually reported on a
previous one he did charging 40 000 a
pop which i guess the lowered price is
because of uh brian rose being a part of
it which makes sense and look i'm not
saying this is illegal right they know
that it's not illegal to sell overpriced
courses it's just a pretty scummy
disgusting thing to do because they know
they don't know how to make you rich
with crypto they don't know whether the
price is going to go up down left right
or sideways which is why instead of
actually investing themselves and making
money that way they sell you on how to
do it and
tell you that they're you're gonna make
money i mean just to give you an idea of
the absolute lack of credibility of
these guys let's actually talk about
some of the crypto calls they've made in
the past brian rose for example on may
5th posted a live stream about tara luna
saying why you need to know about it how
it had all this value locked in it that
was two days before it crashed to zero
and brian deleted this tweet he also
posted on may 3rd about crypto.com's
best kept secret and why you need to
know about chronos the day after they
slashed their rewards and their price
started to fall and plummet and look
jordan belfort is a little bit better
but only slightly like in 2017 he said
bitcoin was bad but then in near march
2021 near the all-time high of bitcoin
jordan belford all of a sudden jumps on
the bandwagon and says he's a bull says
it's going to 100k i think what happens
first before anything long term is i
think it goes higher technically
probably to 100 000 or more but what
happens over the long term i still think
it's an open question i'm a bull
certainly for the short term and i love
blockchain technology overall now of
course bitcoin did not go to a hundred
thousand dollars in the short term and
instead is trading at 27 000 which is
half of the price you would have bought
it at had you bought when jordan belfort
suddenly jumped on the bitcoin bandwag
and these are the guys mind you who are
supposed to teach you the secrets of
wealth in crypto the only real secret
being that there's anyone still left
buying these guys ridiculous courses
because jordan belford is an actual
former criminal who got indicted for
defrauding people and brian rose is a
well-known grifter who dances on a new
topic every day one day it's the digital
freedom platform then he's running for
mayor now he's doing this defy grift
which he will of course abandon as soon
as it's inconvenient so if you're buying
this understand that
you're not learning about the
opportunity you are the opportunity